hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now we're
gonna be doing a lot today we need to
build the nuclear reactor and kiss our
ass good-bye when we jump into this
giant pit but thank you to Carly
Arlington who said the terrifying
suggestion that there might be a giant
monster gaping with its mouth wide open
for me to jump into it when we go down
there which is terrible to think about
but thank you and then devil ninja who
said that the bed if I wanted to find
there's actually a bed that you can
sleep in in the game and it can pass
time that's found in the jelly shroom
caves so those are the purplish caves
that I could go down and I believe
there's an abandoned base in there
somewhere and then wonder human who
reminded me that if I jump down I won't
be able to get back out so I need to
find a way to do that but I don't think
I'm gonna do that I think I'm just gonna
jump then that's gonna be the end for me
and then that's not lightning [ __ ]
that's lightning shot who suggested that
I don't take the the the the diving suit
whatever the diving suit is don't take
it above water it will crash my game so
thank you for that and thank you guys
and the first thing that we're gonna do
is I'm going to build the nuclear
reactor because I have all the materials
that I need right here and it's right
here oh let's keep the panel right here
at the beginning and then once I get
this up in order it needs
uranium which is processed from those
uraninite crystals that I got before so
if I look at this it needs uranium I
believe if I put oh [ __ ] well that
doesn't seem to be working huh it
doesn't take the euro night crystals I
think it needs to be you can only add
nuclear reactor rods to the nuclear
reactor well howdy [ __ ] me that ain't
good enough for what I'm doing but
either way I'll figure out how to do
that just signal what you doing in here
you take the urine in the night crystals
and you turn them into uranium and then
I'm assuming somewhere in here reactor
rod ah I need lead do I have led down
here please tell me I've let down here
if I don't have led down here I'm gonna
be so pissed
goddamnit I want to keep cheating on you
guys but Oh some things need to be done
I'm sorry I'm a dog goddamn it
yeah I'm a dirty dirty cheater I'm sorry
I need lead I can't get anything it
takes me so long to bring materials and
I thought I had everything that I needed
to do I apologize but I want to make
sure you guys can actually see these
things in a timely fashion and save me
from all day going back and forth in
between the servers in here which is
hard enough as it is
I have titanium I do have that have it
him bah bah bah bah bum bum bum bum bum
bum
and he okay so we got that we got the
rods now we just need to shove our rod
in this machine
and it'll give us holes so much power
what I am I don't know how much power
seems to be going up at a good clip Wow
actually that's going up at a decent
clip considering that the eight
bioreactors that I had going on was
giving me was giving me maybe one power
every two to three seconds this has
given me a good amount of power this is
doing more than those eight bioreactors
so it may not have a lot of flash it may
not be spinning and zapping I was hoping
it was gonna be doing that but this is
working it's good hooray we got a
nuclear reactor okay so that's beside
the point because the next thing that we
need to do we need to upgrade the uh we
need to upgrade the pressure
compensators whoopsie dip see ya know
they were there oh no I got him in my
and you upgrade them at the modification
station so in the seamoth upgrade you
upgrade them to press your compensator
mk2 and then you take that one you
upgraded to pressure compensator mk3 now
this takes a lot of material doodles and
oodles of material you need a total for
just 1 MK 3 5 plasteel ingot switch
takes 5 titanium ingots mixed with was
it lithium ah
may your god that was so weird I think
my ear just like hey you know everyone's
gonna get like a high-pitched ringing in
your ears for no reason I thought it was
coming from the game but it just faded
away it must have been from my ear I
have no idea that was weird anyway sorry
about that but you need 5 plasteel ingot
s' and a toe
love to aluminum oxide crystals and a
computer chip this is a lot and if I was
on the surface yes totally I would go
get this material by myself but on 900
feet below meters
I'm 900 meters below I'm about 3000 feet
below the surface it's pretty far okay
but we do have what we need now so I'm
gonna make a pressure compensator mk1
and then I'm gonna make a pressure
compensator mk2 and then I have exactly
don't mind my giant fan in front of me
that I'm homing like my big here but I
have a pressure compensator mk3 which I
if I go out here to my little excavator
right here who looks oh so delightful
I'm very happy about him
oh wait did they wait did they push out
an update cuz these guys look different
wait a minute they pushed an update with
these guys are different wait a minute
if that panel was not fully fleshed out
before oh now no get back here where'd
it go oh oh no no no no oh god I need
you don't drop on me up on me okay it's
fine okay so boink ah crush depth now
1,700 years yeah it's not that okay but
1,700 meters
that's pretty damn deep that is pretty
damn deep so what I'm gonna do it's time
to go into the deep it's time to
literally jump off in nowhere into the
black nothingness that is down below
there and explore the deep now this is
the only way to get this deep as far as
I know because the Cyclops can't go down
there the seamoth certainly can't go
down there or maybe it can
so the mk3 show the seamoth cannot go
down the only way that it can survive
down here is because this is the old
school this is the old school pressure
compensator that allows it to go to a
thousand meters which is not good enough
for me so enough stalling it's time to
go down
way down I probably should bring like
you know an extra power cell with me but
I'm not gonna do that but captain whoa
boy
oh wait whoa hey ha ha wait what is that
supposedly you're supposed to be able to
get yeah oh you're supposed to be able
to get materials out of like very deep
things okay Wow whoo
are you ready guys cuz this is it once I
go down there I literally don't have a
way of coming back I really hope I spawn
at this particular base yeah before I go
I need to get one more thing it's not
gonna help but it's gonna make me feel
better repulsion cannon because I don't
know if there's gonna be anything down
there
I highly doubt there's any monsters down
there well just in case I'm not gonna be
[ __ ] around okay
whoo ha ha oh [ __ ]
god damn it I'm sorry it's just like
sliding into it man
oh that was scary okay enough stalling
let's go down whoo okay here we go oh oh
oh what was that Oh still falling okay
we've hit bottom there's a lot of lava
flow we've only reached 1,100 meters but
it looks like there might be further
down over this way Oh God
okay there seem to be a bunch of lava
flows down here nothing to be seen thus
far seems relatively normal
except you know the horrible
implications of a giant underground
river of lava ownest oh I don't want to
fall in that that probably would kill me
an end to my adventure very shortly oh
man what am I looking at okay so
navigating this terrain is gonna be a
bit treacherous but I'm gonna have to go
down there eventually because it seems
like this just goes oh ooh and remember
the exosuit that was the name of it the
exosuit has like a jet which helps you
navigate around considering it only
Falls downwards man
there's some serious lava flow down here
now the last time I was down here this
was not fleshed out this did not have
terrain like this maybe towards the very
very bottom of it it had trained like
this but I wasn't even able to reach
that because with the old seamoth depth
it can only go to a thousand meters and
everywhere else had to go like I had to
get out of the seamoth and literally
dive down and man this this light isn't
doing a whole lot just doing enough
buddies oh my god there's resources down
here goodness let me see if I can get
this with my new hammer fist yeah it
yeah yeah [ __ ] where am I gosh [ __ ]
where'd I go there you are
come on pal pal pal yeah I'm gonna hop
out for a second
whoa hey diamond cool alright so this is
probably the only place to get diamond
which is probably gonna be a risk/reward
thing I bet diamond is used for
something like advanced recipes if not
now then definitely in the future but I
bet it's gonna be dangerous to come out
here not only because of the crushing
depth but also because of the monsters
that might lurk in the dark
if you know what I mean okay so we seem
to still be going down I don't know if
there's a point that reaches max [ __ ]
god damn it stop that I'm on edge he's
hitting down whoa whoa whoa you guys
seeing what I'm seeing
what a wow what is that holy [ __ ] what
have I found whoa whoa Nelly
hi what is that whoa what is that I
don't know what that is whoa God dude oh
I think I remember that wait a minute
when I came down here before this wasn't
all fleshed out but when I came down
here before I remember there being these
tall spires and I tried to go to the
base of them and I believe I'm down near
them now oh my god what is that oh it's
gone now [ __ ] I make sure I don't fall
into a lava pool whoa that's awesome
that's so cool oh well I thought those
are things but that's so cool how did
these form I mean oh no obviously it's a
video game it formed cuz the creators
made it this way but god damn it oh it
still makes me curious just like the
giant skeleton it's like how'd that get
there I know someone drew it up and put
it there but goddamn oh that's nuts
oh that's so nuts you know I uh like
it's an easy comparison to make between
underwater environments and space and
what's weird I'm getting some vibes like
from an alien world
I know obviously I'm on an alien world
but I'm getting like a above-water vibes
like exploring the depths of space oh
man that just goes up doesn't it holy
[ __ ] oh man oh wow what the oh my god oh
my god oh my god I'm still not on the
highest one but I don't feel a need to
go over there all right Wow okay
continuing on I just have to take a look
at that those guts
here we go boo boo ski oh wow also there
seems to be uh an even farther down like
holy [ __ ] way farther down so you know
let's not hesitate oh my god is that
whoa oh oh no oh no oh no why did I come
down here oh [ __ ] alright so this is
getting even farther down I believe this
is farther than anything that has been
here before just kind of testing the
limits of my ability but there's another
crevasse over there I'm gonna go into it
yeah oh my god it goes farther down
really oh my god oh and it gets dark
down here
whew that made the lava turn a weird
shade of green whoo what's happening
what was that getting awfully noisy down
here whoa what is that what am I looking
at here what is that what is that oh my
god what is that what is well I seem to
have gotten to a place where I felt
necessary to play some additional music
it's like a river of magma it's just
that the atmosphere is so dark and dense
down here oh geez that doesn't sound
good
hey let me hop out for a second whoa oh
my god holy [ __ ]
okay let's go for it
whoa Nelly we're gonna play hopscotch an
extreme game of the floors lava
holy [ __ ] hmm BuChE BuChE BuChE BuChE
Wow
what what Oh
I'm so happy I'm so happy right now and
terrified I'm equal measures of happy
and terrified because oh whoa okay music
stop Oh Nelly Oh Nelly whoa Nelly
whoa Nelly whoa Nelly Nelly I can't even
see where there might be another
possible way to go because it's so dark
in here oh it's so dark so densely dark
oh boy I'm surprised that I'm not
squished like a tin can
the second I leave my exosuit there's
something over there just another lava
flow I believe but this must be the
lowest point considering all the lava is
pooling down here must be but I can
follow the lake a little bit down this
way because it seems like it stretches
on down this yonder away but I do
believe I have found the lowest point
whoa whoa whoa whoa okay whoa whoa whoa
what the [ __ ] whoa what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is that hello hi holy [ __ ] that
is the creepiest thing I've ever seen
was sabi 1 why are you down here what
the [ __ ] man
Oh Oh what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
I know that's probably just like the
developers putting this down here for
some reason what the [ __ ] man oh it's so
weird
I didn't spawn that in I did not spawn
that in that was not me that was there
that's just down here why oh well that
is stucked that is beyond creepy I have
a funny feeling that like if this was a
horror game as soon as I turn around and
look back he's gonna be standing right
behind me oh god that is terrifying oh
it's so weird it's so weird oh man is he
like guarding the entrance to something
like horrifying like that no one would
be able to see him who says pure luck
that I came across him man now I'm just
afraid I'm gonna row well where am I
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I'm falling
well I'm falling where am I going oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
um okay where the [ __ ] am I why is this
would the [ __ ] I'm just stumbling across
the weirdest [ __ ] brah my god
oh my god what the [ __ ] is this I just
fell in a hole and what is this it's
it's a part of it someone built this
someone made this down here I'm like in
a fishbowl is this gonna be like is this
like physically is this like the lair of
the sea dragon or the sea Emperor
oh man what the [ __ ] whoa oh oh wait a
minute what's down there there's more oh
boy okay well this this might just go
beyond I found another hole but it might
just go beyond my crush capacity at this
point what can you do
we've gone this far let's save and jump
down okay here we go
oh geez oh geez mistake mistake mistake
mistake mistake mistake Oh God Oh it was
just a pit oh it was a trap oh [ __ ] well
try thrust out here I'm not gonna happen
cuz I think the exosuit takes way long
to die yeah climb on yeah oh I think I
found a way you can kind of like glide
up on the walls if you keep the thruster
going ooh ooh ooh scoot a little bit
b'doop b'doop
scoot little baby do scootaloo boopadoo
I'm gonna survive
cuz I'm probably exploring something in
the physics hey hey I made it out well
damn
look at me right I think that was the
deepest point in the game but I survived
and I made it out where am i what am i
doing where am I going
yeah let me let me stay down here for a
little bit I don't want to go I don't
want to try to go back up but it seems
like there's a way I can go back up at
the moment because there's one more
thing I'm pretty much done for this
episode wow I did not expect there to be
so much stuff down here but there's one
more thing that I want to do before the
end of this episode and it's there's
another thing that you can spawn in that
is fully animated now and has
accompanying terrifying sound stop doing
a dance I know you're excited please
stop dancing for a second let's make a
mistake huh [ __ ] god damn it Jesus what
where the [ __ ] am I what happened to my
suit oh [ __ ] oh God well it robbed me oh
why is my soon over there did it pick it
up oh jeez oh hi hello how are you doing
I am fine I please get in No
do that can I please get it thank you
okay but I was high well okay well I
don't hear anything so maybe they were
lying about that but now the guy is
fully a hello Wow
hi he's fully animated well he's big
he's a big man but jam but look at the
size of that forger
well that's okay I expected there to be
sounds but maybe he's aggressive now
this is a bad idea
Oh dad yep let's see if the repulsion
can it works on him probably doesn't are
you stuck in something oh hey you seem
to be stuck in something can I help you
are we stuck let me get you out of there
there we go did I help him oh my god
where's he going he went into a wall
escaped husky husky hey
stasis field oh good you go
we go ready go goddammit they keep
bugging out probably cuz it's too deep
from pulling oh whoa gotcha oh [ __ ]
left him I had him that I didn't have
him had him but I didn't have him had
him and I've lost him hey buddy
whoa what was hidden oh god of course
I didn't know that was possible removing
I mean I figured it would be possible oh
hello
well god damn damn damn damn well I
suppose that's it then
well holy [ __ ] how's the thing so anyway
that is all the time I have for
subnautica thank you guys so much for
watching I'm not gonna do another video
until there's another big update
obviously I think I've gone through
pretty much everything that there is in
these new updates but I'm gonna keep
this all here and ready for when the new
next update comes so we will see that
when we get to it thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
I guess this is a metaphor for a
threesome bloop-bloop not for the
kiddies